body language what'd you say about who
you are
the minute you enter a room before you
even open your mouth to speak body
language can also be defined as our
presence or even sometimes our gravitas
we've all been in those situations where
we've been in a networking situation and
we see someone come in the room and
immediately we take notice maybe even to
the point where we watch them walk
across the room and then we watch them
grab a cocktail and maybe even be in a
conversation and although we can't even
hear a word that they're saying we know
that there's someone important and that
we want to connect with them presence is
how you carry yourself posture hand
gestures facial expressions if I were to
be talking to you
and suddenly slouch my shoulders what
reaction does that produce in you do I
seem any less confident or unassured
what if now I bring my shoulders back
I'm claiming more space I'm claiming my
space in the room when we're giving
pitches how frequently do you walk
around the room how frequently do you
keep your hands close to the to home or
are you extending them out one tip the
bigger the space the bigger the hand
gestures so you want to scale it if
you're in a large room and especially if
you're taking the floor if you are
giving your pitch you want to be
embodied you might even want to walk
around the room I'm serious about this
when you walk around the room you're
claiming the space you also might be
inviting more connection with particular
people who are in the meeting as you're
getting closer to them in space you're
owning the room you're owning your
message it's putting people at ease and
saying you have no
problem being in control so frequently
we go to give a presentation and we keep
our feet very close together this is
giving me the psychological impression
that we don't want to take up too much
space this is not a power move for you
so have some good distance in between
your feet clean your space almost as if
you were a bit of a superhero taking
charge of the room and carrying the team
on your mission to get funded racial
expressions solidify our connection to
what we're saying so if I said I'm so
happy to be here thank you for having me
how does that come across it feels
pretty dissing genuine it is so much
more fun for the audience of a pitch to
be watching someone who's engaged who's
embodied with the information that
they're sharing think of sitting through
a pitch that someone's just saying and
these are the statistics and this is my
idea and I think it's really really good
and it's gonna change the world versus
this is my idea look at these statistics
this is going to impact the world in
ways that are going to be so remarkable
and notice I just become more alive not
only with my verbal communication but
with my nonverbal communication my hand
gestures my facial expressions and I'm
moving my body so the more movement you
can have and I want to be careful about
this suggestion because they don't want
you to be nervous moving swaying or
pacing we don't want that I do want you
to strategically walk around the room or
even if you can go from one side
addressing the room back to Center and
then back to the other side
and back to centre incorporating
techniques with your body language is
going to help sell not only you but also
your message and it's going to make you
a lot more likeable and likely to be
invited back